Speaker 1: Let's hear from you, the people
that make this all possible without you.
I'm a guy in a room with a mic, and it's very,
very sad.
Let's first hear via Discord from Alex from
Baltimore.
Remember that it is David Pakman dot com slash
discord.
That's the place to go, Alex.
You're on what's on your mind, my friend.
Speaker 2: Okay.
David, can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Cool.
So I have a question about, I guess, America
in general.
So especially if you listen to more left news
and opinion, it's basically the opinion that.
America, pretty much America can't do anything
right.
Everything about America sucks is that.
Is there anything that America is actually
still?
Better or the best in the world at that's
actually positive, I don't mean, you know,
gun deaths and incarceration numbers or anything
like that.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, I mean, I don't know
who who has that perspective on the left.
Speaker 2: First of all.
Well, I well, I guess no one says it outright.
OK, I guess.
Who do you think believes it?
So I guess instead of.
I guess it would be more.
I do I don't want to throw other shows on
point.
Let me put it, let's
Speaker 1: put it different.
I think I have a good way to couch it, which
is OK because the left wants things to be
so much better.
Sometimes it sounds like the Left thinks the
U.S. is much worse than the right, like the
U.S. is much more down on the U.S. that there
is that kind of what you're saying.
Speaker 2: Yeah, kind of.
And I guess if you were to consume so much
of that news, it would be easy to fall into
that trap.
Right?
Just curious, is there anything that America
is actually just as good, if not better than,
say, Western Europe, but we're always comparing
ourselves to listen.
Speaker 1: The U.S. is by nature of being
so geographically large and diverse by nature
of having so many people.
And by nature of having so many different
industries that are that are possible in the
country has so many things that other countries
would dream of when it comes to, you know,
so many of the best universities in the world
are in the U.S. so many of the best medical
facilities in the world are in the U.S.. When
you look at medical advancements, so many
come in the United States technological culture,
you know, all these different things.
I think there is no question about that.
I think where the left chimes in and says,
Whoa, hold on a second is that someone like
me, a Social Democrat, believes so much of
the good that comes from those things is reserved
for a very small slice of the population and
is not helping such large swaths of the people
in the U.S.
But yeah, without a doubt, the you mean, listen,
I could live somewhere else, but I choose
to live in the United States because there
are a lot of great things about the country
and there's a lot of things that need to be
fixed.
Speaker 2: Josh, you know that that's a good
insight, you know, that I appreciate that
I do have a I like to ask you travel questions.
I appreciate that you humor me on them if
that's all right with you.
Sure.
Do you ever take into consideration the the
government in question when you travel to
a place, for example?
I'm getting into the history of China.
And I would love to go see their history and
culture.
But the CCP is right.
Do you do you ever consider such things when
you travel or should we?
I do,
Speaker 1: and I think I do.
I consider it.
And to say whether we should really depends
on the individual.
And Alex, I don't know what's making so much
noise in the background, but it's crazy.
I don't know if you're running some kind of
a, you know, hydraulic pump or something.
Speaker 2: Know a guy was driving by on.
Oh, OK.
So here's the thing.
Speaker 1: I consider it at the end of the
day, if given the opportunity to go to like
Russia or China when things settle down, I
would I would do it because I want to learn
about it.
It doesn't mean I endorse the government.
You know, I've because my family's from Argentina.
I've traveled to Argentina during every government,
almost all of which I am not a big fan of.
So yes, I consider it and I would factor it
in.
But ultimately, it's up to every individual
to decide, what am I getting out of this versus?
Am I tacitly supporting the government by
even going?
And it's a very personal decision.
Speaker 2: Right, and China is a good example,
because if you support a business, you are
supporting the government because they're
so intertwined.
Yes.
Speaker 1: Less so than in the
Speaker 2: past, but to some degree, yes.
Speaker 1: Good questions, Alex.
I appreciate it.
Great to hear from you.
There's Alex from Baltimore with some very,
very strong questions and some really interesting
stuff going on in the background as well